HBO's Last of Us is a monster hit about
a post-apocalyptic world and based on
the popular video game of the same name
and there's a moment in episode 7 that
kind of rocked everybody that was of
course the kiss between Ellie and Riley
it was a really cool and touching scene
and one that some parts of the world saw
a really confusing version of the orbit
Showtime Network or OSN is a company
that delivers content to much of the
Middle East and North Africa region and
while they didn't take down the whole
episode especially since it's a global
sensation and they don't want to lose
viewers they did make a rather awkward
cut in the middle of the moment we see
Ellie and Riley like super close and
then suddenly Ellie apologizes I'm sorry
so unless she had too much of the bean
casserole for lunch that day it was
probably pretty clear she was
apologizing for something that got cut
of course viewers in other parts of the
world know that it was the very brief
kiss that was taken out